hey ich werde heute original süßigkeiten
testen und die nachgemachten produkte
ich hab so was schon öfters mal an den
trends gesehen und ich weiß nicht ob die
leute das auch so machen aber ich werde
dabei eine augenbinde aufziehen und also
nicht beurteilen ob das besser aussieht
sonstwas sondern einfach nur den
geschmack ich habe insgesamt fünf
produkte gekauft und werde jetzt einfach
gleich gegenüber stellen meine freundin
wird mir die dinger immer angeben und
ich ziehe dabei eine augenbinde auf
damit ich nicht erkennen was das
original was der fake ist und um das
ganze aufzupeppen habe ich mir auch noch
etwas überlegt und zwar werde ich die
augenbinde auf lassen und nachdem ich
beides probiert habe und meine
einschätzung abgegeben haben was ist
richtig was ist falsch passiert entweder
gar nichts oder ich krieg nach 23
sekunden eine schelle einfach weil ich
selbst behaupte dass ich mich ganz gut
auskenne mit süßigkeiten und glaube dass
ich ein paar erschmecken kann ja dann
würde ich sagen starten direkt mit dem
video das er sogar aktiv und ich
verbrachten letzten dank just so runde
eins leute wir haben hier kitkat wafer
durch die alle kennen wafer duo ist die
nachmache milchschokolade knusprige
waffeln genau das gleiche ist also die
wafer google minis kosten 1 euro 69 und
kettcar 42 also falls jetzt bleibt
schmecken sollte dann wäre es für eine
große bereicherung für die checks
jährige ich sehe überhaupt nichts aber
nichts wirklich versprochen
ich bin sehr gespannt so sehen die
beiden ausgepackt aus also läuft ihr
müsst wissen nicht lieber auch kid cut
also falls wafer du jetzt nice ist dann
im moment vielleicht können wofür du und
ich freunde werden
ich bin jetzt echt sehr gespannt
[Musik]
schon sehr nach kitkat andere bitte okay
das ist jetzt echt nicht direkt gewusst
aber die kids schokolade hat irgendwie
so einen eigenen geschmack daran habe
ich erkannt also punkt eins geht an mich
ich bin mal gespannt wie viele ich heute
richtig geraten kann und wie viele
stellen nicht bekommen
das voll der neues werk in die frage
eigentlich wollte dass ich so
schlafbrille als merchandise-artikel
rausbringen dann schreibt es jetzt in
die kommentare
ein fahrzeug das video gefällt dass
michael so leute nächste produkte die
wir gegenüber stellen sind eminem surges
big hit muss man glaube ich nicht weiter
erklären das sind die nuss und die nuss
becketts und ich werde einfach von
beiden eine probieren und gucken ob es
erraten kann hier kosten übrigens jetzt
die big hit 87 cent und die m&ms 250 der
dileo tester leipzig und lustig
ich hab so anziehen weil dieser moment
in dem ich dann sage was richtig und was
falsch ist und dann warten also einen
schlag oder auch nicht nein egal wir
legen los sozusagen m & m nutzt wenig
anders müsse aber ein viertel auf
geräten
das war es ein modell das letzte was
leute das hat viel lustiger geschmeckt
das erste thema für bitter geschmeckt
also die schokolade war so richtig
komisch dabei heraus also leute ich bin
ziemlich gefälscht also ich hätte nicht
gedacht dass das so gut ist bei der
nächsten gegenüberstellen werden wir mal
ganz klasse und zwar mit
vollmilchschokolade versus alten
vollmilchschokolade also nur seinen
namen schokolade aber fair trade und
preis gegenüberstellung milka 95 cent
alpen vollmilchschokolade und 39 cent
ok also weniger als die hälfte bin
gespannt übrigens leute macht euch keine
sorgen
wohin diese ganzen süßigkeiten kommen
süßigkeiten werden immer auf gelesen was
als ob das wahr personifizierte mega ich
war mir so sicher viele leute vielleicht
ein bisschen eine große klappe am anfang
so von wegen alles okay ich habe jetzt
einen von drei raten so am anfang nicht
zu folgen für ca sie kommt als nächstes
haben wir bei teenies und kokos schoko
minis also original wirst du es
nachmachen
die cocos schoko minis kosten 1 euro 79
und die bounty - zwei euro 99 also ich
bin echt ein bisschen überrascht ich
meine ich hatte gerade zweimal gesagt
dass die nachmachen besser schmecken und
die haben jeweils weniger als die hälfte
gekostet
der crazy und übrigens weiß jetzt gar
nicht gesagt haben in den nachmachen ist
meistens sogar noch mehr drin persönlich
400 gramm mehr oder so ziemlich folgt
testen wir weiter für chippen dass das
erste sagte nicht das bounty weltweit
erstmals probiere ich das heute wieder
irgendwelche schlüsse ziehen bevor ich
habe angst zu sagen aber das zweite war
das bau- und thq da mach ich mir jetzt
echt sicher hat sich schon leicht
unterschieden bei einem rein weißen ist
es voll komisch es klingt immer so wenn
leute über sowas reden wieso wannabe
gemäß dieser cocos geschmack hat sich
irgendwie viel später entwickelt sage
ich mal bei dem ersten also bald ein
bisschen dunkler schokolade auch die
carry schokolade naja also bei mir läuft
letzte gegenüberstellung kommt in 321
prinzenrolle versys doppel keks dass
prinzenrolle klingt schon mal besser
hier seht ihr noch mal 500 gramm versus
diana gehört also probier's mal okay ich
bin bereit
[Musik]
uns ist gerade aufgefallen dass sie
immer sage dass das letzte original ist
am mittag auch dieses mal wieder das
letzte war die prinz wurde
leute was bin ich denn für eine pfeife
naja leute aber ich hoffe mal das video
hat euch genauso viel spaß gemacht die
mir wir haben jetzt noch kiloweise
süßigkeiten die wir auf essen können
hatte ich in allem will ich sagen you
tube video in voller erfolg gewesen
ansonsten jetzt für die ganz krassen
unter euch die immer noch dran geblieben
sind schreibt mal bitte süßigkeiten in
die kommentare
ihr könnt euch lieben gerne hier mein
letztes video anschauen falls ihr noch
lust auf ein weiteres video habt und
mich hier unten abonnieren ja das war es
von mir dann sehen wir mal nicht mehr
wieder tschüss